-Elle a fait interdire en France
une milice nationaliste turque
et déclaré la guerre
à une influenceuse
aux 2 millions d'abonnés.
Ceux qui l'ont côtoyée la décrivent
comme "discrète mais obstinée",
ce qui l'a sans doute aidée
à se faire élire
députée Renaissance du Rhône.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Sarah Tanzilli.
-Bonjour.
-Alors, vos deux parents sont
d'origine arménienne.
Ils ont toujours vécu en France
mais sont liés à ce pays,
vous aussi.
Pour vous, que signifie
"d'origine arménienne" ?
-Eh bien, écoutez,
l'histoire de ma famille,
c'est une forme d'héritage
pour moi.
C'est d'abord ça,
et puis je crois
que c'est rapidement aussi
devenu pour moi
un engagement,
un combat
pour porter
la cause d'un peuple
qui est très méconnu
et qui, pour autant, a été frappé
d'une immense injustice,
et donc ça bouleverse.
On a envie de porter ça.
-C'est, en effet,
votre tout premier engagement.
Avant l'engagement politique,
vous défendiez
la cause arménienne, très jeune,
dans différentes associations,
et vous avez aussi présidé
la Maison de la culture
et du peuple arménien
à Décines,
dans le Rhône.
C'est dans ce contexte
que vous avez pris la parole
le 24 juillet 2020.
Une prise de parole, on va le voir,
qui a été interrompue
assez rapidement.
*-L'Arménie souveraine
et indépendante est attaquée.
En pleine période
de pandémie mondiale,
l'Azerbaïdjan a décidé
de mettre ses menaces...
*Contestations
Je vous demande de rester calmes,
messieurs dames.
*...
(Ca va pas le faire.)
*-Messieurs dames, ça sert à rien
d'y aller à 100. Restez calmes.
-On comprend qu'il est en train
de se passer quelque chose
derrière la caméra,
mais on ne comprend pas
bien quoi.
-Alors, en réalité,
ce rassemblement qui avait lieu
suite à une offensive
de l'Azerbaïdjan sur l'Arménie,
en soutien à l'Arménie,
a fait l'objet d'une attaque
de jeunes de la région
qui se revendiquaient
d'un groupuscule
ultranationaliste et mafieux
qui s'appelle Les loups gris.
Et donc on a fait face
à de jeunes hommes,
pour certains armés,
-De couteaux,
de barres de fer ?
-Couteaux, barres de fer...
Ils cherchaient
à se battre, tuer,
frapper les Arméniens.
Ils sonnaient aux portes
dans la rue.
-Vous imaginiez vivre ça
un jour
sur le territoire français ?
-Non, à aucun moment.
Ca a été, effectivement,
un moment bouleversant.
Je regardais ces images
avec un peu d'anxiété,
parce que ça me rappelle
effectivement des mauvais moments.
-Et ça s'est passé donc
à deux reprises, à Décines,
avec cette milice
nationaliste turque.
Avec plusieurs associations,
vous avez demandé
et obtenu l'interdiction
des Loups gris en France.
Est-ce que ça vous a valu
des menaces de leur part ?
-Je n'ai pas reçu
de menaces directes,
mais je pense
que ces organisations
connaissent
les associations
qui portent ces sujets,
notamment le Comité de défense
de la cause arménienne
dont j'ai été membre
et avec qui on a déposé
cette demande de dissolution,
donc il y a évidemment une pression
quand on connaît les acteurs...
-Là,
on les voit défiler justement
lors de l'une de ces descentes
dans les rues de Décines.
Les Arméniens forment
une communauté très soudée.
Vous êtes une membre active
de cette communauté
et en même temps,
vous revendiquez votre attachement
aux valeurs républicaines.
Est-ce que le communautarisme
est compatible
avec le modèle
républicain français ?
-Moi, je suis
une enfant de la République.
Je suis le produit
de l'école de la République.
C'est ce qui m'a construite
intellectuellement.
Et c'est aussi ça qui a construit,
finalement, mon engagement,
donc il y a un vrai lien
entre les deux.
Je crois qu'il n'y a pas
de difficultés
à ce qu'il puisse y avoir
des communautés en France,
à condition
qu'elles aient toutes en tête
que notre bien commun
à toutes et à tous,
ce qui garantit notre liberté,
ce sont les principes
de la République.
-Dans votre famille,
votre frère vous a précédée,
en quelque sorte, en politique.
Vous êtes discrète sur le sujet,
mais il a travaillé
pour le Parti Socialiste.
Il a été collaborateur parlementaire
de François Hollande,
puis conseillé parlementaire
de Bernard Cazeneuve,
d'abord au ministère de l'Intérieur
puis à Matignon.
Ca veut dire que la politique
avait une place importante
dans votre famille,
pour qu'il y ait...
-Oui, ça a une place importante.
Je ne sais pas si c'est le cas
dans toutes les familles,
mais ça nous arrivait souvent
de parler politique entre nous,
à table, avec nos parents,
et on a un engagement commun
aussi
pour la cause arménienne
avec mon frère.
On n'a pas forcément toujours
les mêmes idées,
mais ça nous a appris
l'engagement politique,
l'importance que ça peut avoir
sur la vie des gens,
et donc que c'est important
et que ça compte.
-J'ai lu que votre père
est engagé à gauche,
tendance plutôt Socialiste.
Votre mère est plutôt à droite.
-Plutôt.
Elle n'est pas encartée.
Elle n'a pas d'engagement politique
mais elle a plutôt
des idées de droite, oui.
-Emmanuel Macron,
il concilie les deux ?
-Peut-être
que mon expérience personnelle
m'a montré
qu'il y avait du bon
et à gauche et à droite.
-Vous avez d'abord eu
une carrière
de fonctionnaire
territoriale à Lyon.
Certains
qui vous ont connue juriste
à la métropole
de Lyon vous décrivent
comme discrète mais obstinée.
On peut faire de la politique
quand on est quelqu'un
de discret ?
-Ecoutez, a priori,
manifestement, oui.
Je pense que la première
des qualités,
c'est effectivement...
-L'obstination ?
-Oui,
une forme d'opiniâtreté,
une volonté d'aboutir
et d'acquérir une énergie.
Je pense que c'est important.
-Quand on est en politique,
il faut convaincre,
il faut aller vers les autres,
il faut se vendre,
en quelque sorte.
-Je pense que la discrétion
n'empêche pas ça.
La discrétion,
c'est parfois être intimidé
dans un moment comme celui
qu'on est en train de vivre,
et ne pas être forcément
attiré par les médias,
en revanche,
je pense que dans une relation
personnelle, individuelle,
j'ai une capacité
à aller vers l'autre
plus importante.
-Pour obtenir l'investiture
d'un parti aux législatives,
on milite sur le terrain,
on prend
des responsabilités localement.
Vous, vous avez pris
un chemin différent. Vous avez été
collaboratrice parlementaire
de la députée
Danièle Cazarian en 2017
et vous lui avez succédé.
Comment ça s'est fait ?
-Si Danièle Cazarian
avait fait le choix
d'être à nouveau candidate
à sa succession,
il était tout à fait logique
que ce soit elle qui porte
la candidature.
Elle a fait un choix différent,
et j'ai dû me demander
ce que j'avais envie de faire
à ce moment-là
et ce que j'avais envie de faire,
c'était vraiment
de continuer à défendre
les intérêts
des habitants de mon territoire.
C'est presque une mini France,
cette circonscription.
Il y a plein de choses,
il y a une vraie diversité.
C'est un territoire qui m'a plu,
auquel je me suis attachée
et que j'avais envie
de défendre
à l'Assemblée nationale.
-Vous travaillez
sur la défense des droits
des femmes et des enfants.
Dans ce contexte,
vous avez effectué un signalement
au procureur de Rouen
contre une influenceuse,
Poupette Kenza.
Qu'est-ce que vous lui reprochiez
exactement ?
-Ecoutez,
je lui reprochais d'avoir publié
notamment une photo
de sa fille,
dans une position...
relativement suggestive,
et donc
de mettre en danger
son enfant.
Je crois
qu'on ne mesure pas...
l'importance et la gravité
que ça peut avoir pour ces enfants
d'être exposés aussi jeunes
et d'être exposés comme ça.
Ces images...
-Sur cette photo qu'on a choisi
de ne pas montrer...
-C'est plus raisonnable.
-...on voyait la culotte
de cette enfant
et la photo, vous dites
qu'elle a circulé
sur des sites pédophiles.
C'est ça ?
-Elle a circulé... Enfin,
le nom de cette jeune fille,
en tout cas,
de cette petite fille,
a circulé sur des sites
pédopornographique sur le Dark Web.
Donc il y a une vraie exposition
de cette enfant.
Malheureusement,
elle continue.
Autant, vous savez, je pense
que les parents
de 2023-2024...
Je comprends tout à fait
qu'on ne se rende pas compte
de ce qu'on fait
quand on publie des photos
de nos enfants sur les réseaux
mais quand on sait que nos enfants
sont en top tendance
de sites pédopornographique,
je connais peu de parents
qui publieraient encore
ces images de leurs enfants.
-Derrière,
il y a la question du droit
à l'image des enfants, un sujet
sur lequel vous travaillez
avec Bruno Studer.
Est-ce que le procureur
a donné suite
à ce signalement ?
-Ce que je peux vous dire,
c'est qu'il y a
un certain nombre
des followers
de cette jeune femme
qui ont participé
au cyberharcèlement
qu'elle a voulu organiser
à mon encontre.
-Elle les a incités.
-Exactement.
Ils ont été reçus,
ils ont été auditionnés.
Il y a des procédures
qui sont en cours.
Moi, ce que je souhaite,
ce n'est pas forcément
de stigmatiser
ces jeunes filles-là,
c'est surtout des jeunes filles.
Ce que je souhaite,
c'est que cette femme
qui, elle, est une adulte,
et qui a lancé ce cyberharcèlement,
elle soit responsable.
-Sur ces images,
on voit l'un des messages
qu'elle a adressés à ses abonnés :
"Signalons ce tweet
"qui incite au harcèlement
envers mes enfants et moi."
Dans la foulée, vous avez reçu
des messages d'insultes
sur Twitter, notamment.
Là, on en voit quelques-uns.
Je les lis parce que ça peut
être compliqué à lire sur cet écran,
mais "Sale pute, tu n'as pas honte".
"Sarah la pute,
je vais te piétiner."
"Retourne en Arménie
"te faire génocider."
Vous avez déposé plainte
contre elle. Ca a donné
quelque chose, pour l'instant ?
-C'est encore en cours.
Je vous pose ces questions
car on a le sentiment que la loi
est en retard
sur la société,
et la loi,
ce sont les députés qui la font.
-La loi est aussi
en train de se faire,
et vous le disiez,
sur la question notamment
du droit à l'image de l'enfant.
Moi, je pense que la proposition
qui est rapportée
par mon collègue Bruno Studer
et que je soutiens,
c'est une proposition
qui est intéressante, équilibrée,
parce que ça permettrait
dans des cas comme ceux-là
d'empêcher
les parents de continuer à publier
des images de leurs enfants.
C'est quelque chose
d'efficace et d'équilibré.
On est encore en train de faire
la loi, vous avez raison,
mais sur la responsabilité
pénale
en cas de harcèlement,
le cadre législatif est là.
Maintenant,
au juge de faire son travail.
-On passe à un sujet plus léger.
Notre quiz !
-Ah !
-Je vous explique.
Vous allez compléter
les phrases
que je vais vous proposer.
On y va.
-Je pouvais passer
les soirées en famille...
-Et maintenant ?
-C'est plus compliqué
en tant que députée, d'abord
parce qu'il y a une activité
parlementaire nocturne importante,
et parce que quand on est
en circonscription,
on est sollicités aussi
sur ces tranches horaire-là,
et comme j'ai deux petits garçons,
ça me coûte un peu.
-Vous les voyez moins.
-Oh là là.
Euh... Peut-être
Frédéric Mathieu,
qui copréside avec moi...
Il est député La France Insoumise
et c'est donc
plutôt un adversaire mais à la fois,
il copréside avec moi le groupe
d'études sur les Kurdes.
-Vous arrivez
à travailler ensemble.
-On arrive à travailler ensemble.
-Dernière question.
-J'aurai réussi mon mandat
si j'arrive à mieux protéger
les enfants victimes
de violence.
-C'est votre priorité ?
-Moi,
j'ai été bouleversée par ça.
Je pense que c'est
le point de départ de beaucoup
de drames de notre société.
Beaucoup de difficultés
que ces enfants
peuvent rencontrer
une fois adultes
sont liées à ce qu'ils ont vécu
dans l'enfance,
et je crois que vraiment...
Depuis que j'ai pris conscience
de la gravité de ça,
je me dis que si j'arrive
à en sauver certains
à l'occasion de mon mandat,
j'aurai été utile.
-Merci beaucoup,
Sarah Tanzilli.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...